je vais à chaque fois désigner une
personne autour de la table
je vous le dis on va regarder un extrait
et je vous poserai une question sur
l'extrait il faudra bien mémoriser tout
ce qui se passe d'accord et celui qui va
perdre devra faire un gage juste après
si vous donner la bonne réponse vous
désigner quelqu'un de votre choix autour
la gamme
si vous donnez un mauvaise réponse c'est
vous qui le faites la première il va
falloir se kbc donc sensuellement le
visage avec du cirage sur les mains pour
7 pour ce premier gage
je vais prendre jean michel maire
jean-michel mais regardez bien cet homme
qui pose de manière sexy dans son canapé
à regarder
vous avez 5 secondes et je vous posais
une question juste après vous pouvez
jouer chez vous attention regardez
en fait le nom de florange dans le
bouquet si vous gagnez vous désigner
quelqu'un sait combien à combien près
non mais on est on est pas vrai l'ehpad
majorité d'orange donc je dirais 5,5 et
bien jean-michel il y avait là on s'est
donc perdu moi je suis allé leur dire
regardez cette caméra
mettez-moi de musique un petit peu
érotique vous retournez vous retourner
je me retourne maintenant attendre le
rapport sur ces parties et votre
écriture de très sensuelle il est quoi
mais les durs tout ceci est dur oh la la
quel regard les héros nous a pas demandé
de vous déguiser
imessage
attention ça va être isabelle morini
bosc
si vous perdez vous allez devoir simuler
un orgasme en imitant nicolas sarkozy ou
jacques chirac pas ça je le sens bien
d'accord imitant gaz mais le hockey est
difficile à nogaro et victoire nicolas
sarkozy johnny ou 7 sur latvala et
choisir qui jacques chirac
très bien alors déjà ou pato et vous
êtes peut-être gagner attention en scène
avec un sosie bleus font de rihanna
regardez cette photo 5 secondes alors au
fond de la photo il ya un mur peint de
couleurs lesquels alors que dale orr
c'était quoi
non mais j'ai même pas vu les photos ben
alors mais alors vous dites quoi je
dirais
gris jaune très jaune regardez regardez
c'était s'était bloquée vous avez été
happé par la photo alors j'ai même pas
vu alors allez-y vous allez donc simuler
l'orgasme en imitant jacques chirac
ça fait quoi alors
jordan minimum mais pas l'aller c'est
très réussi s'extraire aussi attention
on va en faire une autre et là je vais
prendre alors là je vous le dis faudra
prendre une clinique hier de pâte à
tartiner et se retourner en faisant un
sourire séducteur
d'accord je vais prendre jean luc revol
gérant lui attention regardez je peux
gagner encore regard si vous gagnez vous
désignerez quelqu'un jean-luc à tokyo
voici la troisième photo regardez bien
cette photo c'est un cousin à moi
attention c'est bon alors ça lui
n'oublie steckel de quelle boisson cette
photo fait à la promotion dans une
guérilla
ben oui je prends des buts c'est mathieu
non j'ai vraiment la preuve cette
émission un truc est pas du tout comment
il savait sangria même pas aimé la bulle
des prix sans plus attendre à calais ou
refaites jacques chirac vous attention
alors et vous allez vous retournez vous
fait assurée sur cette caméra là et vous
dites oh oui c'est mathieu devant vous
attention avec les fausses ou rien alors
mesdames et pas laissés sur les noms
alors et retournez vous
le moose ils le mangent away
et
je pense que c'est bon je pense que
c'est bon pour aujourd'hui un sexy
jacquouille la fripouille